thank you
[Music]
okay welcome back to another very
special careful boys where we are
currently I'm off the Record
and today we are talking about something
what was something that you were falsely
accused of oh oh dude I have a really
weird one yeah so um there was just one
uh one of my ex's best friends she
brought around this guy who was like a
pathological liar who would just make up
the weirdest [__] right and um I guess
he kept lying to his girl about where he
was and he would always tell her that he
was with me
so then I kept getting calls and like
she would always be like what happened
he said he was with you like where is he
like and she would believe him over me
all the time so it was like so
exhausting it got his lies got to the
point where um
she asked them like why are you always
around this guy this is I was still like
18 at the time he told her that he was
actually an undercover FBI agent and he
was doing a sting operation on me
because I'm a drug dealer
wow oh so he said that so like no matter
anything you said would already be
destroyed Yeah
the more the more interesting did she
believe him yeah she told she told my ex
that that's what he said and then my ex
was like she didn't believe that she was
just like what the hell is this guy I
don't we were both like dude this guy's
crazy that guy's craziest yeah he was
just nuts was he 18 too yeah he was 18.
18 year old [__] wow
doing an undercover sting operation in
high school
Jump Street dude he's working with the F
but he's a 12 year old genius he was
like one of those um he was like one of
those half white half asian like super
pretty boy thugs like he gets away with
a lot of things yeah so like he just
says whatever the hell and he was like a
hustler kind of mentality and was just
one of those dudes and at that time like
this hot sexy gangsters that's they were
like oh don't they there was a guy am I
really charismatic he was one of those
dudes that got transferred there because
he got kicked out right and then when he
came in it was like all the chicks
with that because all the chicks he
doesn't even talk in the town instantly
and you know what criminal you know what
his [__] name was
Roman oh my how [__] sexy is that
that's my cousin's name yeah but it's a
sexy man it's [__] hot he was already
off hot bro that's not fair it's already
a hot sex y dude
my parents know he was gonna be a [__]
thing yeah
bro man let's go both oh my god let's go
let's go yeah
half white half Filipino from Santa Nas
and he had a shaved head so he looks
sexy as [__] and then his name was Roman
of course it's never been [__] around
your male model Roman let's say
Meanwhile my name is barf so like those
be with that guys like that could tell
girls anything they wanted in the
bathroom
I thought it was bored he got pretty
privileged dude yeah dude that's insane
right so whatever happened with that so
did he bust you or what did he get this
thing off did he catch you for your
crack I never saw him again after he he
was basically like crashing at my place
and my dad like was so pissed that he
was there that get them out of here
that's the guy that my dad ended up
driving like all the way to Escondido or
some [__] to like so that he would just
be gone
my dad killed the guy the guy's buried
this we never saw him again maybe my dad
I like to think that the FBI guy had do
and then you're walking out of the
bathroom and you're like oh I just got
him down downstairs
um yeah I know I I'm I'm I'm with I'm
with the bureau
Catch Me If You Can yeah dude don't take
my whole [__] wallet that was crazy
man
I feel like everything I was accused of
I was guilty of yeah like setting the
massage place on fire
but you got accused of robbing some
houses
came out to be true yeah same here when
you were robbing houses it's like what's
like what are you looking for what's
some good [__] honestly
it was just for the thrill you know it
wasn't like like there's people that are
actually like scoping [__] out it would
go to TV whatever like like casing out
the house for me it was just like I just
wanted to be there so like when like the
older homies were like we're gonna go do
this
because it just felt so cool you know
I'm like get to be away from this stupid
Buddhist [__] mom like to be with
[__] some cool guys doing some crime
that makes sense yeah it's true
okay so uh in elementary school
all right I've talked about this before
but who knows a lot of new people
I was uh pulled aside all of a sudden I
was on safety patrol right and yeah with
the orange vest and the clipboard orange
vest yeah wow I was a cool kid I used to
beat up nerds you sound like a nerd in
the story about that no no that's not
true I was the sickest kid there exactly
so then um I got pulled aside one day
and and they're like Hey Stephen you
need they all call me Steven back then
uh you need to come to the principal's
office and I was like okay and so I get
there and I'm expecting to get like a
merit badge or some [__] an award
helping kids cross the street all day
but then they're like they're like hey
um you're being accused of sexual
harassment and I was like oh what the
[__] is that even me
because I was so sheltered I didn't
raise I didn't know much about sex stuff
at all so then um they've they said that
they found a letter that my neighbor had
found in the Woods by our houses why
yeah we all lived this place
um in Virginia next to George Mason
University where there's like a bunch of
wooded area and then this chick like
found a note in the woods and she's like
yeah like I found this note in the woods
it's kind of [__] up like Steve
Green's talking about how like hey
Courtney
it was a chicken or neighborhood she was
like she was like a nice girl in her
neighborhood hey Courtney come to the
woods tomorrow and like wear something
tight and sexy and I was like I don't
even know what
no it does
where's something Titans yeah eyes like
and they but they read the note to me
and they're like you're going down
she got you you son of a [__] where
you're like I don't even know what that
means Meanwhile your boner's just like I
wish I wish
but I was like was the paper written in
crayon no it was yeah it was written in
like in like shitty [__] pencil was
it even yourself
I didn't write it I didn't know what the
[__] this even was I didn't know what
Titan sexy meant it was clearly written
by somebody older than me like an older
kid for sure it sounds like an adult
so but they're like you're going down we
got yourself a bit we're looking for you
for all of 11 years
so I was like all right so then my mom
and dad get involved oh my God I got
that oh bro they're trying to expel me
from the school because they're like the
sexual ration is crazy and I was just
like so confused I didn't know what the
[__] was going on but then my sister my
honest sister who I did ask to wear
something tight and sexy
my sister this is why she's so hot to me
she
went to every kid in my neighborhood and
she had them write down [__] for her as
writings
she's such a nerd dude she started
cross-reference and [__] I almost wanted
to beat her ass because I'm saving
Patrol we beat asses if you're being
nerdy but then but then so so she was
like getting all these writing samples
and then she was just like she was like
this isn't your writing and I already
know that so like you're Innocent but
I'm gonna find who [__] did this [__]
and then I'm gonna suck your dick while
we take them again
I remember like it was just
has your sister ever seen Eddie Jacob no
I I will start
I'd be too flattered to know that she's
watching I'd be so funny dude you're
taking him back he's so flattered to
those who's working like I got married I
moved on
so uh so no so she she's like hunting
neighborhood and I think that the
squeeze that my sister's putting on all
the kids in my neighborhood was enough
where the chick who found no go figure
comes to my door knocks on the door and
apologizes with tears in her eyes and
like I wrote the no I'm sorry I had a
crush on you yeah exactly she had a
crush on a good way of admitting she had
a crush on me but why would she cause
that noise
I don't know kids are [__] nuts
that's true but she's older than me wow
but the adults that said
adults that said you're going down
they're [__] dumb dude I know exactly
dude these are that's that's why adults
in schools are the most dumb [__]
people ever like the way that they over
accept what kids say is so [__] dumb
dude Steve Green you're kind of a stud
bro hey y'all today's video is brought
to you by Warby Parker Warby Parker
offers you everything that you need for
happier eyes
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
even eye exams and you can shop with
them online or in stores glasses start
at 95 including prescription lenses try
Warby Parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try on at
home for free and there's no obligation
to buy ships free and includes a prepaid
return shipping label so it's pretty
easy I take a quick little quiz and then
I get to choose my cool little
sunglasses this is mine and you get to
try it at home and you like look at
yourself in the mirror and for me
particularly this really helps because I
like to try on everything before I go
out and uh
make the purchase sometimes I buy stuff
online and I don't like it at all and I
regret it but with this no regrets I
tell you something I like to spend money
so I got stuff that's cheap expensive I
got gas stations sunglasses I got stuff
that cost like three 400 bucks Warby
Parker is up there with the quality it's
very sweet and that's why I like it and
look at this case wow this is nice case
see that
keeps everything nice and protected and
you can try all these on so you can go
which ones make me look ugly which one
makes me look handsome and you can keep
the ones that make you look handsome and
you can tell them your prescription and
they can send you the glasses
with your prescription while you look
smart you look like you're about to ride
a motorcycle or something a cafe racer I
thought I looked like one of those guys
that play piano but can't see the keys
oh so try five pairs of glasses at home
for free just go ahead and go to
warbyporker.com off the Record yeah
you're kind of a stud dude everyone
thinks I got a big old dick but like my
dick hasn't grown since that eight how
many of them
it's been big
he was off balance all the time big from
that time he's stepping on his dick all
the time dude no so so that was [__]
crazy because that was my first brush
with like people can really say everyone
can just assume that you did something
wrong and by the way yeah like on it and
being honest right now like I was really
sad about this because when I went to
safety patrol which I really liked a lot
because I thought I was helping people
which is [__] stupid and I agree
um for a little kid here the way that
they treated me it hurt me so much yeah
to know that like something that I
really cared about like um
like being safety patrol yeah like I
just you know I thought that was like
part of like you know I'm gonna help
people and [__] you're no I'm being
honest I'm being honest that's crazy I'm
being honest at the age I know she's
talking about that sucks dude but that's
why you [__] hate Authority like I do
man I don't believe people anymore yeah
because because I it happened to me so
after all that went down
what happened with the school apologies
nothing nothing no apologies nothing
nothing just skirt under the rug they
didn't do anything no principle
apologies to me the people who are
accusing me instead of going down and
they did say that I'm not exaggerating
it's like we got you man yeah they're
trying to get a confession yeah they
didn't say you're going down but they
were trying to scare the [__] out of me
I didn't know what was going on I just
genuinely would how old were you again I
was like I was like 10 11 years old
that's crazy you don't forget that you
don't forget and and um yeah I always so
yeah anytime anyone's accused of
anything I I think maybe many of you
have noticed I I I'm very skeptical
because that happened to me and so you
know you just don't forget [__] like
that especially how quick that could be
weaponized right oh yeah and how quick
everyone just just buys it oh we got a
note that says Steve Green wrote it why
would I write why would some [__]
stupid kid write something like that and
then like like oh I'm gonna name on it
because I'm an idiot like it's so weird
and then buried in the woods and then
some chick finds it in the woods and
then she takes to the school or like her
or someone someone one of her friends
takes it to school but it's like
it could also be because right before
that there's another kid that goes to a
teacher with the long pink balloon I was
like you like this Mr Dilly and then so
the teacher is like you're going to the
office sexual harassment and Steve with
the note you're going to the office yeah
so you just get dumped because of this
other yeah you never know you never know
what and what people are going through I
don't know but sir dillian that is
really said that that many adults in a
row are all idiots yeah they all that's
always what I felt though like about the
school system they're like this 10 year
old kids yeah yeah and you have no
priors
nothing I didn't even know what that
meant I didn't even know what it meant
to wear something tight and sexy I
didn't know what that even was about
like what would you wear something tight
and sexy what does it have to do with
anything but now you do though no
now I get why she wrote it
and I get why she wrote it because she
didn't have anything Titan sexy to go
with it [__] what happened to that
girl I'm Petty
[Laughter]
she's killed by icicle cool because
everyone there is gullible [__]
the first thing that they hear your
sister's like Lisa Simpson
she is honestly smart and she'll like
imagine Lisa Simpson but with like
triple D tits ah wow damn and like a
little less yellow
but she's still like a little bit yeah I
mean she's pretty white so
your sister's dope for that though man
she's the best she's a gangster dope I
don't deserve because you had like one
person fighting on your side she knew
she knew she interrogated me and she
smoked and she smoked her out basically
and she said she's smoking hot and what
about your parents what did they do the
whole time were they just like this is
some stupid ass kids we gotta go work
yeah
so you're out of jail no my mom was very
weirded out by it all yeah yeah and it's
left field my dad had nothing to do with
it he was just like on another planet
he's like tight and sexy huh well he was
dealing with his own [__] I found out
later but like I think I would have been
laughing too hard like for too long and
then I would have been mad at the
teachers for the way that they handled
the situation and I would have probably
lectured them all
after that I laughed at you the whole
day yeah thank you after that I never
did anything with like safety patrol or
school and you're like [__] no from
that moment on you're like [__]
authority authority that's exactly what
happened yeah do they take it away from
you no no
I actually threw it into a lake
I threw a towards like you imagine
you're [__] you're [__] airplane
you had to pick it up yeah they're not
Aaron did there so I kept on going like
that and then hit the ground what about
your Ribbon the LA [__] the big lit
ribbon that goes yeah that yeah that I
just rolled up and all the kids came up
to the next week to like Steve what
happened you're not safety patrol
anymore and I was like I'm done with
that I'm done I'm done no apology like
to the student body or anything to like
exonerate you so for them rumors and
[__]
damn damn [__] Virginia that's a
pretty crazy story for uh such a young
man
that was in the 90s bro yeah you could
have had a sex offender thing on your I
guess yeah
but I'm with you Brad I got your back
you could your life could have been
ruined
accusation you know what's pretty funny
when when you do do a lot of bad [__]
sometimes you would do a lot of sexual
harassment but like but like the the
ironic thing is the kids who are
constantly doing bad [__] when they're
falsely accused they get so mad yeah
because they're like no I really didn't
do this one yeah but like they're always
doing that [__] but then internet body
language expert so like he's lashing out
a lot I think he's very guilty yeah
right even though they're like
constantly guilty it's funny to falsely
accuse someone that's always doing wrong
extra mad because it's like this time I
didn't
can you actually catch me when I steal a
car that was me I was I pretty much
lived in the principal's office
you were there more than he was huh yeah
I was always yeah probably I was always
there
and then when they accused me I was like
that was me
[Laughter]
I'm trying to think of the time where I
was wrong I was I was accused on like
for the correct things and they were
right like when I got in trouble for the
[__] when I somehow I don't know how
I convinced these kids to do this [__]
but we I convinced them to jump off the
swings remember that thing I told you
guys like I was so fun to jump off the
swings you know when you like you teach
kids to jump off the switch for the
first time but the only reason we did it
was we've been teaching them jump on the
swing so that when they're in the air
you run up and you kick them in the nuts
as they left because they're like
wow so you have to time it and just run
and just go and then they were like the
the principal is like I have reports
that you were uh you're kicking some
some boys and and I was like yeah I was
that's absolutely brutal when I taught
improv we did the opposite to to build
trust
dude you were doing jackass before it
was even great like kicking third
graders nuts and then they were like the
principal's like um he's like I'm not
gonna tell your parents but I will I do
have to tell you this one thing he was
like you can kick you can kick a boy
there and prevent him from having
children the rest of his life and then I
went I wasn't trying to do that he's
just trying to be like America's
Funniest Home Videos
[Laughter]
damn
or even like guys that don't really know
how to pogo stick oh I'm like why you
get out and there's like one point they
just [__] crack their nuts oh
nothing's better than the old Asian guys
doing Kung Fu practicing hella hard
while getting it
by the way that's a great gif it's all
the one oh of you yeah how can you
punching my dick
[__] [__]
yeah man